speaking of threesomes Lucifer I believe
actually I believe he actually missed
out on one near the end of the season
do we oh yes yeah yeah he got screwed
another way we also we did a loose I did
allude to one in the second episode yeah
but Sir
Oh happens and you also you know you're
bringing a character to life from a very
beloved series as well the comics how do
you approach this character that you
know it's not just you know a great
character it's also Lucifer it's the
series for Bibles out you're talking yes
it is based on the best-selling book
about he was this attention character in
that but no so how do you know like were
you kind of like were you offended or
kind of excited when they offered this
to you I wasn't offended I was very
excited um it was it was a strange one
because I've been quoted as saying this
before and it's true I didn't know it
was based on a comic book when I got the
job and then when I was reading about
getting the job it said based on the
comic book and I was like oh my god
right well maybe I should read that but
I'm kind of glad it wasn't because the
original kind of script the original
pilot script was written by Tom Kapinos
of Californication Fame
that's his mum and he'd written this it
just written this brilliant character I
mean it was just kind of it for me it
was a bit like a blueprint on the page
there I kind of knew what I wanted to do
with it from that and so I'm in a way
kind of glad that I hadn't sort of
polluted my my choices by going
elsewhere and we've always been very
careful from the start of the show to
say that this is something that was
inspired by the comic book as opposed to
you know a literal translation of it
yeah and that is uh you know that's a
that's a tough line to play of being you
know a devil but also somebody we have
to like yeah well it was one of the
things that people ask me about it is
was it written as a British character
hmm and it wasn't specified to be honest
in the script at all and I did try it as
an American character and he just he
said
like a dick so and then I realize you
can say whatever you want in the British
accent in North America and everyone
thinks you're really charming so yeah
you guys get away with everything
everything everything um do the fans of
a character like the devil is there a
specific level of like kinkiness or like
how do you mean Damon you know like you
know like oh my god you're the devil I
love you you know there is a bit of that
um yeah yeah I think yeah yeah that's a
bit of another questions once uh
yeah I think if you've done a lot of
these conventions this is this is my
second come we're going to get the
weirdest [ __ ] as Lucifer yeah you're
gonna get poetry there's gonna be
they're going to show you their peers
yeah yeah things bits and pieces yeah
what notes yeah cuz they're gonna think
that you're Lucifer yeah and there will
be some who will come to worship you
right there yes they're all looking
forwards it's mostly a good experience
lots of goats it's not here anymore
but I was a massive battlestar galactica
fund oh and we've got our Lucifer panel
tomorrow and I was blown away when they
names who my mum was going to be in the
new season of this yeah Scioscia health
is gonna be with us tomorrow so I'm very
excited so this is like a dream come
true but she's playing your mother yeah
hands is a bit weird they are messing
with you it's a bit eatable yeah uh yeah
yeah yeah I'm still struggling with that
your show ended on a huge twist and
cliffhanger when you told your brother
on the show that your mother had escaped
from hell did you know like what have
you been given the script and was that
in there or did they tell you what or
not you know well actually that was um
that was kept from us until the very
last minute and I was really I mean I
was I loved it it was a literally a
jaw-dropping moment reading it for the
first time I was like what
and then so on the spoiler thing I kind
of wish in a way that we hadn't sort of
talked about who was going to be mum in
the next season but you because we as
actors always get Cyril you can't say
this you can't say that and then it gets
PI out there anyway and you're like oh
but yeah I rather not know but I
understand that you want to sort of live
you know I like watching sport so I'm
kind of like I'm not wondering if
someone wants to tape a live sporting
event and what you afterwards I'm Latin
that yeah I can't do that let's just
I've gotta be alive what about online
comments or tweets you guys you know a
lot of you interact how's that you know
any kind of situations where you were
like wow that was really spectacularly
strange there was it there was a there
was an exchange on Instagram uh between
my girlfriend at someone who basically
they said they they thought that I was
actually God and they were really
Lucifer and and she was the [ __ ] of
Babylon oh yeah which but it was all
done in good you know good spirits from
our anyway and so we on followed up but
yes it was it was quite as quite some
quite interesting you again Jason's like
the super fan of everyone is like yeah
I'm commenting it was like my dream come
true my question is in the episode we
see that Lucifer loses his power
Cellini's around Chloe and so I'm
wondering is that because he's has true
feelings for her and she has true
feelings for him and that choice kind of
comes into play like that free love you
and so you try to command other people
and so just starting of that place okay
great free will if that really yeah um
um this is something that we will
continue to investigate actually in the
second season we haven't got any
conclusions really amongst us about that
yet but I certainly will have a lot more
fun playing that dynamic
because um the the you know the great
thing about the Chloe and Lucifer
relationship is that they are both two
characters who are completely disarming
of each other and so that they've got no
choice but to be most like themselves
with each other so I've got I've got no
concrete answer for you is the is my
answer but I'm it's something for sure
that we will continue to to press the
button of and investigate in the show
you